happy Monday reject nation it's Greg
Alba here and I'm John Humphrey we are
going to watch today the exclusive
trailer for the reign of the supermen
the DC animated films are freaking
awesome people and the depth of Superman
I think came out a little bit ago and
this takes place right after I remember
learning about this comic book series
forever ago it's about like several
supermen some different variations that
think steel is actually in here and the
other ones were like kind of DNA
versions of Clark Kent himself
I'm sure the trailer will elaborate a
little bit more I know a little bit
about the behind the scenes of this
before we go into this I want to give a
patron of the day shout out to a man
named Mikhail Linden though our awesome
homeboy all the way from a small town in
Sweden Mikhail I believe your name if
I'm going off a memory correctly means
gift from God and you know what you are
a real gift from God or if there was a
Superman in this world and he died I
would take it upon you to uphold that
mantle because you wear glasses and are
kind of mysterious so you seem like a
Clark Kent I don't know if you even
weigh lift or if you're strong at all or
anything like that you might be puny on
the inside of it who knows either way I
put my faith in you buddy thanks for
being part of our patreon page was so
long and thanks for always hitting me up
with awesome questions about film
franchises that I haven't seen
I'm here Eradicator
what
cyborg superman grabs a Superman
the Man of Steel is dead we suck it's
time for human beings stop relying on
leaves and start saving our Superman
Superman there is only one Superman
Superman in the lelee planet said
Superman is dead it painted a target on
earth how do we begin to fight that
whoa wait a minute what just happened
there yeah
Justice League justice Lee's got wiped
out Clark ah well I believe in the death
of Superman Clark's not actually dead
he's kind of in some weird Kryptonian
like coma yeah you guys can correct me
super-special not about what goes on in
Justice League it's here this is
something else entirely I actually read
The Death of Superman when I was
elementary school and I didn't see you a
movie one of the animated movies that's
not the one that recently came out it's
they do cover it but the rain is
Superman when I heard about this story
ages ago and this is something that I've
always wanted to see adapted into the
big screen I've always thought this
would be a very fascinating look of kind
of like Superman is this you know big
symbol of hope and what happens when
that symbol of hope is wiped out yeah
Bruce Wayne forms the Justice would
these four supermen they all represent
kind of a different variation of Clark
Kent
in a way side of his personality or
something like yeah yeah and in certain
ways I mean I know you got steel in here
who doesn't have any of like that
Kryptonian DNA actually I think the guy
who plays Black Lightning Crest Williams
is the one who plays steel here and I
actually think Cameron Monaghan if I'm
not mistaken who plays the Joker in
Gotham or eight Joker's in Gotham is the
guy who plays Superboy so you're already
getting like multiple DC crossovers
Jerry O'Connell I believe it's cyborg
superman I don't know who's playing the
Eradicator but yeah I mean you kind of
got like the Superboy who really like I
don't know cocky kind of likes the
spotlight looks like a cool yeah I
schools already got the little glasses
and stuff he's someone who like enjoys
being the hero and loves being in the
center of attention and steel is I
believe a man who was actually you know
at one point encountered Superman
then when Superman dies he takes it upon
himself to like build his own identity
in the form of Shaquille O'Neal ha ha
that's something I always appreciate
about especially the animated movies
when they start to explore territory
like this bringing in you know different
iterations of the character and
exploring and from different sides and
even if it is like based on an actual
comic book arc I'm always glad to see
these kinds of things come to the big
screen and like DC especially like this
is some of the stuff that always seems
to be their mark it's like when they hit
the mark it's usually on this kind of
stuff also Superman is a character that
feel like a lot of people rag on for
being you know I've got too many powers
or he's you know too much of a Boy Scout
or whatever and so I like this idea of
taking you know a bunch of different
super men who come from kind of a
different yeah like you said side of
Clark's personality or a different side
of Superman and kind of encapsulating
them into individual characters and
exploring it that way I think is
something that could actually make
Superman that much more interesting for
people who both love Superman and people
who aren't so is hot on Superman this is
pretty intriguing to me and like of all
the characters all the heroes that I'm
intimately familiar with you know
Superman has never been a favorite but
this actually got me really intrigued
and then you have a you know Eradicator
and cyborg superman who evidently
represented kind of a darker side of
Superman you know they're like I drew
Eradicator is a little bit more kind of
what you'd expect if you were to just
hear about the Kryptonians son coming
here to protect Earth through you I feel
like instead of getting like charming
the Superman you would get this version
of him cyborg superman don't really know
much about he's Superman but he's also a
cyborg he's a child of Superman and
cyborg well I think cyborg superman was
originally a cyborg and then taking part
of like Clark's DNA it's like it looks
like it was human first then cyborg but
I think it was originally cyborg and
then human elements at Clark were
applied to him and then you got this
storyline that's progressing I don't
really know much about the details of
the storyline that unfolds here but it
looks like at first they're gonna be at
odds with one another oh yes as it
should be in first half they're at odds
then by the end they probably team up
and at the end I think Clark Kent is
probably gonna come back which is what
that tease is right there super yeah why
are we fighting this is cool
an orgy why are we doing this we are the
symbol of hope between each other and
also this element that they were teasing
upon here too because in the death of
Superman Lois land is a very important
element there and like if you think
about like the most iconic image that
comes to mind for me of the death of
Superman yeah and is often the cover of
them is the one where Lois is creative
Clark Kent and she's shown a lot in this
trailer so I imagine that a real
emotional arc and a real emotional
storyline will probably come in the form
of Lois interacting with some of these
supermen she's gonna have that moment
with all four of them yeah just cradling
like which one of you is far when you
also got the Justice League in here to
which I'm you know sure comes out of the
comic and stuff but I'm excited to see
how they factor in with you know all
these different super men at hand you
know yeah and it looks like I mean
something pretty devastating is raining
down on them at the end there I guess my
question with this too is what happens
with all these guys when Clark comes
yeah yeah I don't know how like insanely
accurate these DC animated storylines
are - the comic books themselves but I'm
not like there's a Superboy series
there's a steel series I don't really
know much about cyborg superman
Eradicator doing their own thing like
where they go to after this but when I
see these kind of trailers it makes me a
little bit sad that none of these come
out in the theaters like yeah they
should I feel like some of these
especially something like this would do
so well in the theaters that if anything
like this is something that I like I
said earlier I hope becomes a live
action movie yeah definitely I mean
especially for DC that's something I
feel like I don't know the the budgets
and all the stuff if it would actually
be lucrative for them but like hey
people showed up for the Killing Joke
and that wasn't even their best by a
long shot and so yeah it would be nice
to see these come out in the theaters
and yeah like these storylines like Ike
I wish DC could get their film wing
together enough so the point that we
could get to stuff like this that's a
little just more off the beaten path
like this is a more specific story lines
together characters we're familiar with
but you know we've seen a lot of team-up
so we've seen a lot of solo hero movies
like this is the kind of stuff that I'm
looking forward to and I feel like this
is the kind of stuff that they could use
to carve out their own Lane
you know and I feel like they're slowly
getting on their way with movies like
The Joker project that they have with
Joaquin Phoenix and some of these other
like birds of prey and things like that
you know going off on more specific and
kind of out there versions of their
characters and stuff I don't know I I
keep hoping that that's just around the
corner but even so I mean these are some
of the best things that DC seems to be
able to make right now are these
animated films and so this looks pretty
sweet regardless of all that all right
guys well rain is Superman are you
excited for this one do you wish it was
in the theaters you can guys can comment
below increase engagement on videos it's
Monday
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell and
also check us on patreon we got TV show
reactions Q&A is love to have you become
a patron ejected I